no I don't I don't believe in a class I
you know I hate to always sound like a
middle of the rotor I don't believe in a
clash of civilizations at the Muslim
people are Muslim people around the
world are probably like everybody else
around the world people are more or less
the same they care about their children
they care about the opportunities they
have they care about freedom and
self-expression and when they feel you
know whether or not their worldview is
is right on this you know when they feel
dictated to or terranize deaven if it's
the tyranny of a culture even if it's
the tyranny of Mickey Mouse you know
invading their homes they you know
they're there they're going to stand in
opposition and I think there's a sizable
number of Muslims by no means a majority
who you know who feel threatened by the
by America's place in the world and by
the export of American culture and the
militarization of their region and and I
don't think that makes it a civilization
class because then that implies that
it's a battle to the death and you can
never win people over and I think we
know that's not true and I think history
tells us that's not true that you know
people make decisions that are best for
them and best for their children and
their families and their economic
well-being and their safety and if they
and and and if you know and they'll
change their minds and their worldviews
according to that but do I think that
it's all overblown and then in fact
there is no you know army of radical
Islam that in fact September 11th was
just an isolated incident and as
somebody has one Democrat recently told
me you know if you if you've gone to
sleep on September ten two thousand one
and woke up you know last week you think
that we'd had twelve cities destroyed
we've completely overreacted I don't
agree with that i think i think it's a
serious defining threat for this moment
I think there are people trying to kill
us I think there are many people trying
to kill us I don't think this is the Red
Scare you know that John Birch Society
and bob dylan's thinking about looking
under his toilet for communists and I
think this is I think this is a a and a
relatively organized and very dangerous
group of people who who can and probably
will get access to the worst kind of
weaponry we know and if we didn't if we
didn't take that seriously as a foreign
policy priority I think we would not be
you know we would not be fulfilling our
responsibilities to the world